back here at home metro police arresting
an 18 year old they say is responsible
for two deadly shootings alonzo brown is
charged with those crimes police say
both happened near tropicana and boulder
highway one last week the other in may
as victoria saha reports police believe
there could have been more violence if
he wasn't caught
18 year old alonso brown was a suspect
police were looking for ever since he
shot and killed a man coming out of a
convenience store on june 23 quickly
realizing he was connected to a murder
at a bus stop in the same area on may 4.
the
suspect seemed to stalk the victim
there appeared to be a random
killing there wasn't any apparent motive
from what we could tell witness
description showed brown wearing similar
clothing and surveillance footage from
the may 4th and june 23 murder the
footage was grainy metro police used all
their resources to identify brown our
detectives were canvassing in the area
and they identified a person that
matched the description of alonso police
say brown took off running and police
chased him he was arrested on monday and
there were two guns found on him making
police believe brown could have striked
again there's no such thing as getting
away with murder in las vegas during
thursday's press conference captain
corrin praising his team for their quick
thinking and solving homicides in our
area metro says in 2021 their ability to
solve homicides was 95 percent whereas
the national average was 65 percent we
have the best homicide unit in the
country if not the world victoria saha
live local now